after a few violent incidents along
fremont street the city is now working
to increase security city officials have
proposed a curfew and have also
installed metal detectors within the
experience madison kimbrough is downtown
tonight with reaction
if you're down here this evening you may
see an increase in security devices
along with a heavier police presence and
that's because of recent shootings
including a deadly attack that happened
two weeks ago
they should put metal detectors and more
security check ids i love it francisco
flores and his wife kendra are locals of
vegas and with the most recent shootings
it has them on edge this week a curfew
for those under 21 was proposed and on
friday metal detectors were installed
with the hope that it will curb the
violence on the fremont street
experience kendra says as a local she's
happy to see the city take action we
come down for little staycations here
and there
so
if it helps keep
everything safe and
better for everyone that comes including
the tourists i think it's a good thing
in a statement the fremont street
experience president and ceo andrew
simon says quote we established
additional security protocols for the
special events this weekend and believe
the new curfew proposal will be integral
to our efforts moving forward right now
it's still unclear how security would
regulate this possible curfew but
there's already one in place for those
under 18 starting at 9 and 10 pm
depending on the days however minors are
allowed to stay out if they are
accompanied by an adult these kids like
they disrespectful they rowdy we have to
get a hold on it so i do understand that
as for statistics in downtown las vegas
since 2021 robberies are up by over a
hundred percent and homicides are up by
20 percent i think i've seen more of a
police presence like the last two days
down here than than ever before it's
still unclear when the proposed under 21
curfew will be enacted but metal
detectors were installed as of friday
reporting on fremont street madison
kimbrough live local now